is this a movie opening or a truck
commercial carnivals and Spielberg will
lent its name to almost anything these
days honey are the two whole beers here
meant to indicate a drinking problem
did the prop guy not have whiskey
bottles on him main character owes money
to some asshole right out the gate
cliche Wow he owes money to more than
one person what a terrible guy that I
have a feeling I should still root for
for some reason also he owes $30,000 but
since this is a movie about fighting
robots in the near future 30k in 2020
it's probably only like five hundred
dollars in today's money
pull yourself together dude Jesus how
can you tell there's a robot in here
from that distance when it's shrouded in
darkness can we get a picture with him
sure the $5 exploitation of minors also
Hugh Jackman tries to charge little
girls to look at his handbook well let's
have us all you you're staring up at the
ceiling with the Sam Houston Center with
the taste of my Red Cross the last time
I saw you two together Hugh Jackman was
beating your ass but he had adamantium
bones and you were covered in tons of
fat makeup but I could also be confusing
to movies I hate when I do that we
agreed that my box who would fight an
800-pound steer for three grand
the robots are fighting living animals
entertainment in rural America
apparently gets real Roman Colosseum in
the next five years like a girl yeah so
far the only girls we've seen in this
movie we're too smart to get conned out
of money by the quote-unquote hero they
should all try to be more like girls a
robot just punched a bowl in the face
stupid Hugh Jackman turns away from the
field of play to accept kudos from the
audience because he is stupid and also
the movie needed an excuse to fuck up
his robot this could have killed
somebody somehow a fucking bowl beats a
goddamn robot because the movie needs to
show Hugh Jackman's character
down-and-out then apparently couldn't
think of any less ridiculous way to do
that hey give me that like these girls
have parents also girls who Charlie
pissed off just happen to be in the
right place to steal robot legs for
immediate Charlie comeuppance also wait
random child spectators are allowed to
walk off with pieces of what is
obviously this dude's robot just because
he lost the fact that in 2020 we'll
still be calling things redonkulous you
recall Carolyn Fallon why didn't these
assholes tell Charlie about his
ex-girlfriend dying before the fight my
guess is they were waiting until the
main character of the
movie was at his lowest miss Galli who
definitely should have known better
waited we too long to come collect on
his winnings Charles Kenton who is aware
of this custody hearing and we are
expected little known fact roland
emmerich did an uncredited tune-up on
the script to make the deadbeat dad
deadbeat e'er um
Amira's signed some paper that releases
my rights to the custody of my son
well selfish dick had his dick head why
isn't he also wearing a t-shirt that
says I break for me the director said
hey where's sunglasses in a courtroom
it'll make you look like even more of an
asshole thank you we're supposed to go
to Italy this summer with my oldest
friend and his wife two months in
Tuscany and all what the kid can't go to
Tuscany this entire father-son bonding
movie is predicated on the fact that
these super-rich people somehow can't
take the kid to Tuscany Italy has
babysitters Evangeline Lilly isn't
soldering my gadgets in the sea
introduction of the love interest and we
already know everything we need to know
about her she's into boxing robots robot
boxing and is pretty yes let's first go
outside before exchanging this obvious
money envelope couple that seems to
genuinely care about max drives off
literally 1.3 seconds after Max gets out
of the car as though they can't wait to
spend on max free summer in Tuscany the
distance symbolizes distance instead of
simply taking max inside and making a
clandestine transaction Charlie pulls
out an envelope full of cash so that max
can realize he was sold during the
custody drop give me $50,000 to sign you
all vote or skipped this movie is really
beating a deadbeat dad horse man Mickey
row six really Ocean's eleven - this
movie Brazilians are crazy about that
talk - robot crap that's racist right
left good guy who was an expert at robot
fighters figures noisy boy is broken
after two voice commands don't work
instead of thinking it's probably
something very simple Japanese video
games but no eggs always but you didn't
become fluent in Japanese playing them
that's for sure unless a sophisticated
fighting robot full of computer
circuitry somehow doesn't understand
English immediately or have an English
function in its remote control and
requires a manual language selection
also she didn't change his language to
English she changed it to American so
robot will be calling it soccer from now
on assholes
by the way when Charlie was calling
about noisy boy he was apparently
getting a good deal because this robot
was defective in some way with things he
could live with but this robot is pretty
perfect and it's insane it was sold for
only $50,000
plot element finds its way into this
movie via careless key whereabouts can't
decide at the Soviet style robot fight
posters or a sin or awesome this kid is
right and smarter than the adult in this
instance which is just cliche and
unrealistic enough to earnest in well -
i who was sure this robot was defective
after - voice commands didn't work is
now certain this robot is top-notch with
absolutely zero training and without
learning its quirks that is a very fancy
microphone to announce dingy robot
fights robot it's absolutely
unbelievable with money on the line that
the robot control guys are basically in
the middle of all the rowdy fans where
any asshole could mess up the whole
fight by being an overzealous dick look
people are never learning dumb asses I
get it but this guy seems to forget all
too easily that his cockiness cost him
his last robot against a bull yesterday
I think can't believe I'm saying this
about a scene involving fighting robots
but skip what the kid hates hamburgers a
needless affectation passing as
character building that's what you do
right anything you don't need you just
throw away after-school special dialogue
wanton tossing of delicious burgers
searchlights are automated but you've
got a time of Wright's takeoff in 2020
industrial recycling compounds go with
the automated searchlights security
instead of cameras guards or hell even
Rottweilers there wasn't even an alarm
when he cut the lock off the entrance is
that a Space Shuttle in a junkyard are
we to believe that the searchlights
don't even come around to this area they
just dodged the lights a couple of times
and now they can go through this robot
graveyard undetected goddamn this movie
the interestedly mudslide of death is
basically a totally survivable theme
park ride also this movie is so far
basically the father-son version of
Romancing the Stone monkey no ex machina
Charlie just saved his kid which is nice
but he also almost killed him after
having him for literally one day and
whoa wait what's this something hidden
in the mud that will be this movie's
protag about I dragged this heavy ass
robot up a fucking cliff and yeah
totally avoided those stupid
searchlights carrying this thing on a
cart those things are so stupid what
happened I don't know let's rewind
ten-second shall we it took me half the
night dragon I'm out of there so why
don't you listen when kids are yelling
reasons for their filthiness
yeah but wouldn't there be all sorts of
sludge and inside its rusty innards
does this thing work
[Music]
damn it Danny Altman this is the same
music from Good Will Hunting
you didn't think we'd notice did you the
robot is named Adam 8000m like the
atomic age but it sounds like Adam ad am
the first man I'd say something about
how Hetal either anthropomorphizing the
robot here but all I can think about is
pop and odd bad Adam is this close to
the trash cans when we cut away but it
takes like forever and stuff for him to
actually hit those cans this kid's mom
has died and I think this robot is the
first thing to give him a hug casual
vandalism Hugh Jackman is 10 years older
than Evangeline Lilly so you know not
really Charlie beat Nico Tandy
no Nico Tandy put me on my ass in the
12th round Jesus that's the quietest and
visible list Hugh Jackman has ever
walked across the floor without anyone
noticing roll credits
reporters are dicks to kids expositional
reporting recognizes patterns in the
unites is fight called instantaneous
okay that sounds like AI or at the very
least syndromes robots from The
Incredibles regardless how is the robot
fighting governing body not cracking
down on this obviously unfairly
advantageous bulls and as much as I like
you dude you're a bad bet Anthony Mackie
from Million Dollar Baby is right but is
this movie trying to make us feel bad
for Charlie who's been nothing but a
terrible up this entire time we didn't
want to show us that fight because it
probably would have added 10 million to
the final budget so instead let's get a
kid to describe it I told you a burrito
okay first of all kids assuming any food
in a bag is a burger second of all Jack
been ripping this bag with his teeth as
though that was in any way necessary
damn did this dude get character lessons
from ninja before walking on the set
with this the robots and a Hugh Jackman
did they actually film chappie in 2011
but turn it into real steel instead no
it's fighting with the control pad not
like a video game at all humans
that's double racist of course he
actually has 35 seconds after Charlie
says this also luckily Adam gets knocked
out right next to max Oh max can
encourage it to get back up through his
human consciousness let me go
money makes you jackman turn in my old
college roommate prime hoop regardless
of the game or situation can always
swore he could take over for you and
play better than you kid whom the movie
needs to bond with his father over robot
fighting is suddenly amazeballs at
computers and coding movie tries to
break the record for dr. pepper product
placement in one shot and the record for
the amount of caffeine consumed by a
minor in 30 seconds teaching the robot
dance moves may count as comedy barely
but it definitely does nothing to help
prepare the robot for the fighting
challenge is ahead of it well yes time
to do the robot without understanding
that I don't and while they do that I
seriously considered doing myself also
the robot does the robot it was only a
matter of time noisy boy in a whoops kid
use the pronoun game because you that's
why and in the span of one afternoon he
taught this robot boxing we hit that
point in the film it's boxing it's an
underdog story it's time for a montage I
wonder if Adam thinks of clips from
Rocky one through four when he trains
okay so does this look like a fight that
Garner's a four figure payday win or
lose there's like 40 people here are
they on some kind of robot circuit which
includes dive bars formerly bull riding
attractions this movie explains nothing
about the robot fighting circuits
world's underworlds and wheels these
guys get invited to Zeus's sweden and
just leave their fighting robot
completely unattended and nobody with it
to our knowledge dun-dun-duh robot
existentialism also casual family
friendly robot fighting movie basically
shows us the birth of AI as Adam
recognizes his own form in the mirror
and simultaneously fires Russian and
American nuclear warheads thereby
beginning World War 3 I'd like to buy it
all but this offer makes zero sense is
she worried that this upstart robot has
a chance to beat Zeus probably not does
she think that Adam would make a great
sparring partner for Zeus probably not
so what are we left with your kids a
manufactured plot development probably
and just to be clear he's not for sale
tell me besides a few dance numbers has
this kid done anything to endear himself
to us yet because mostly he's been
annoying why does any robot need two
heads for any reason what is the point
of this abomination
it's a strictly marketing purposes
opponent who thinks the hero has no
chance starts laughing evilly because we
need someone to hate in this fight and
after all it's not their movie so
they're the villains and they can go
themselves cliche see those geeks with
the joysticks and consoles you mean you
haven't had to talk about how these
fights are different from backyard
fights and prepared for this until now
fuck have you been doing this whole time
seriously I'm surprised the movie wasn't
literally a Rock'em Sock'em robots
adaptation during the time you guys
figured out and discuss this robots tell
it's amazing Adam isn't already lying on
the ground spilling an oil puddle by now
that's your left but I guess he follows
voice commands so you're all good hey
seriously this kid needs to fall down
another clip or something hopefully one
without a zombie robot ready to catch it
[Music]
this fucking kid oh yeah this asshole
I'm wondering did we really need him in
this movie this will be three minutes
worth of fighting that is pretty
unnecessary to the movie on the whole
except they need to give the hero who's
more conflict did they staged this bull
so that Charlie didn't think he was
gonna get a beatdown only to appear
dramatically on cue five seconds later
what the hell for and can they not get
Adam to protect them even if it's just a
block these guys also a movie makes it
seem like Ricky is a bad guy when in
fact Charlie didn't pay the money he
owed and fled and hasn't been a true
hero once in this movie I don't want you
money Marvin I mean what a dick this guy
is talk about some thankless rules for
awesome actors couple that loves max is
actually somehow a secondary villain in
this movie you deserve better than me I
mean probably robot love is all well and
good but there's a lot to be said for
say going to school and living somewhere
not filled with robot parts did he just
sneak into her bedroom and wait the few
look at the gym
Charlie figures well I haven't done
pretty much anything right in this movie
my just won't lie next to my
ex-girlfriend in bed and see if she goes
for amazingly if she does I'm sorry
about about what happened with her a
vague death is the most poetic debt do
we have any proof she wasn't killed by a
robot we do this one last thing
one night is all we need thank you
seriously after you've just heard that
he was sold got in a fight and basically
the summary of this movie did the kid
really not see the robot in the middle
of the street until just now for a kid
who gets half orphaned and sold and
shuffled around he sure seems to get
what he wants a lot of the time so far
the only things these attractive people
have done are be successful and offer a
fair price for a robot and let a child
have his wishes right
and yet villains movie finds a way to
shoehorn the other characters in the
finale even though it makes no sense
they would be here Hannam Casey
Adam doesn't see round two will be that
an overstate it's welcome an hour ago is
now pissing on my couch and yelling
slumber party over and over me oh sure
let's make this guy a racist too I mean
he clearly wasn't a villain before this
because he was actually in the right but
now he's going to insult a bunch of
black dudes so that we hope this racist
gets taken down
yeehaw you know sure is playing
favorites their interstellar favorites
favorites outside of time and space
killing punching things they were nine
and they allowed him to get back up from
this position before the countdown ended
don't worry there are still mega sexy
babes used as accessories in the world
of robot boxing only now they addressed
like mega sexy robot babes movie steals
the Woody Harrelson from kingpin and
gives the main character a chance at
redemption by coming out of retirement
for the big championship match hope you
didn't forget about shadow mode the way
our former boxing hero can not only
redeem himself but also win the match
and the respect of his kid if Adam is
shadowing Charlie then how does he know
which direction to face when doing this
every single time we've seen him
shadowing in this movie it's been a
parallel image but somehow Adam knows to
keep an eye on Charlie and face the
killer robot at the same time different
arms might win if he doesn't know right
from left
now somehow Charlie knew that this
state-of-the-art rocky marciano of a
robot would run out of juice before
knocking at him the fuck out luckily
he's right does that magically make your
robot have a new power core all of a
sudden why does the right cross
translate into a left cross for the
robot shouldn't the shadowing be the
exact same arms and everything winner
movie decides well just steal the
original Rocky's ending to people's
champion sounds pretty good to me
yay I hate him slightly less than the
chick who owns Zeus don't worry your
secret's safe with me
what secret that he loves him or that
the math has never seemed to add up and
he might not be his kid or both see now
he's emulating the exact things charlie
is doing so what was ever a kid earlier
how did they make that work so who does
the kid live with now does he go back to
his Han does he get to continue
traveling and doing robot fights and
yeah it looks like the ant never really
found out about the payment and the
uncle never gets in trouble for it it's
a happy ending for everybody
with all my friends in the media like
quotes Markus go down from this day on I
would like to be known as the big
Aristotle
[Music]
my life don't need saving you wanna die
cuz that's what's gonna happen on this
very night ten years ago along the same
stretch of road in a dense fog just like
this
we got ourselves a nodder
[Music]
[Applause]
amazingly tail
yo
all right huddle up ladies it's time to
make your fantasies come true
no not those fantasies these fantasies
Doyle is here to make it happen
vandal is the leader in one week fantasy
football or real money with immediate
cash payouts and no season-long
commitment whether your fantasy sports
veteran or new to add entirely vandal
makes it easy to get started making real
money also and will make sports move on
now that I'm competing in multiple games
I don't only care about my favorite team
I care about all the games I have
players competing it and with live
updates from the iOS and Android apps I
can see how I'm doing on the go don't
hate yuck you can also compete in NBA
and MLB games you don't have to spend a
lot to play either vanduul offers all
kinds of free contests as well as people
and starting at $1 wait there's more and
they will match anything you make up to
200 but as far as I can compete with my
friends ie
you guys sign up with a code cinemasins
play in any tournament and you'll
automatically be entered into the cinema
since private leaked I'll announce the
winners after the turn of in so you can
see me stand up keep your hands off my
stack if you're the top of the heap
you'll win two tickets to an NFL game of
your choice but being said any one of
you beating me will earn five cents so
get yourself over to bamboo and start
playing for real money today don't
forget to enter the code cinemasins to
automatically get an ass-kicking by
yours truly